I think your audience needs to know something.
Cause I don't talk about it a lot. Um,
every single second, every word I say,
and every conservative is saying on airways,
but it seems like Fox talk, radio podcasts like yours. You trust me,
you are going to experience a lot of this.
As your popularity has grown by leaps and bounds. You've already got,
I get my share. You get your share and I've seen it.
And what people don't know is literally millions and millions of dollars are
being spent to record every single word we say.
I'm Dave Rubin. And this is the Rubin report. Quick reminder,
everyone to subscribe to our YouTube channel and click that pesky notification
bell so that you see our videos.
And joining me today is the host of Hannity on Fox news,
as well as the host of the Sean Hannity radio show and author of the new book
live free or die America and the world on the brink.
Sean Hannity finally welcome to the Ruben report.
No, I w well thank you for having me. Thank you also,
because you have been an incredible addition to the TV show.
We've got to get you on radio more. Um, part of our,
we have a regular ensemble cast. You're now a part of that. Um,
our audience loves you. The feedback's phenomenal.
I know how popular this podcast is. Uh, you are outspoken, iconic,
classic, a free thinker, uh,
independent believe in freedom and Liberty and free speech.
And you're not part of the cancel culture and boycott and shut everybody down
that you disagree with. And, and frankly,
isn't it crazy that we conservatives are those guys that were the ones. No,
I don't want to cancel anybody, boycott anybody or get anyone fired.
Let people decide, let people have freedom of choice.
Yeah, well, I suppose I could just let you go and say nice things about me,
but I'll [inaudible] because I actually, I got the book yesterday.
I read about half of it so far,
but I want to start with exactly what you just said there.
Cause you said it to me on air a couple of weeks ago,
and I thought it made a really good point that you get boycotted all the time.
You know, media matters and the rest of these guys,
they're constantly coming after you trying to take you out,
take out your sponsors, et cetera, et cetera.
But you personally never call for a boycott for any of the guys that are
doing far worse stuff. In my opinion, then you're doing,
could you just talk a little bit about what it's like to just be in that machine
all the time,
just be in that atmosphere of boycotts and the rest of it all the time.
I think your audience needs to know something.
Cause I don't talk about it a lot. Um,
every single second, every word I say,
and every conservative is saying on airways,
but it seems like Fox talk, radio podcasts like yours. You trust me,
you are going to experience lot of this as your popularity has grown by leaps
and bounds. You already got, I get my share.
You get your share I've and I've seen it.
And what people don't know is literally millions and millions of dollars are
being spent to record every single word we say in the hopes that we
say one word, one phrase, one sentence,
there's one paragraph that either they don't like,
or they'll take out of context or they'll clip so that they could
either boycott us to make us financially, um, not,
not viable, which you know, there is a business aspect of being on the air.
It's not cheap to be on the air,
whether it's a podcast or radio show or TV show,
because they want to silence you.
I can give you my track record going back to the time that bill Maher now I'll
be very Frank. I hate Bowlmor. I don't like his show.
I think it's gotten worse. I think he's radical, extreme.
I disagree with pretty much everything that's come out of his mouth.
I've had him on a guest as a guest or a number of times. Uh, but I,
I do respect his iconic classic style.
I do respect that. He'll say things that he knows will upset people,
but it was people like myself when ABC was canceling politically incorrect.
Uh, that said, no, don't cancel this. Literally standing up for him.
Now we'll never get credit for that.
I've never had or witnessed liberals or liberal groups.
Now they say they're for free speech. They they're pro-choice but they're not.
Because every time there is any effort to boycott any conservative voice,
libertarian voice or any voice, they just don't like, it's always okay.
We got to get them fired, get them canceled, boycott them.
So they're financially, they're not viable anymore.
And then ultimately what the goal is to get their voice off the air,
every single, prominent, conservative, this is not a small effort.
We are talking about tens and tens of millions of dollars to do
this. And it's done. It's an intimidation tactic.
And it's funny because I can tell you,
I can give you a long list of people that I, for example,
I had a huge Twitter feud with Jimmy Kimmel that went on for a while
and I went at him hard and I reminded him of all those stupid things that he
said it all started. Cause he was making fun of Melania Trump's accent.
When she was reading books to children, I'm like,
are we really going to pick on women?
And then I brought up all the old videos of him, uh, you know,
cause caramel loan.
Right? Yeah. Put putting.
Like cucumbers in his pants and approaching women from,
from old shows he did. And then I would always hashtag Disney.
Cause I always knew Disney had no appetite for a controversy not to get them
fired, but to send a message, you're going to be a.
I can be a back now when he really came under fire recently
and apologized for that older skid, as it relates to Carl alone, uh,
like Jimmy Fallon did elite year earlier.
Not once that I even comment on it, I stayed out of it.
I had had my fight with them. I'm not a boycotter I'm not a canceler.
I actually believe that people should have the freedom of choice.
People have to choose to listen to my radio show,
watch my TV show and sign up for your podcast,
which is enormously popular.
It's one of the most popular podcasts out there now and all credit to you,
but you're a target to why is it the left?
Doesn't stand up for freedom and Liberty and free thought and expression and the
free open exchange of ideas. You know, I'll say this too,
they act like they're so outraged, Donald Trump outrageous. And they wake up,
Donald Trump says this or that they're outraged. It is selective feigned,
moral outrage. It's not real. It is phony. It is,
it is selective because they want to act all outright. That,
that outrage,
if you're that offended by what you're hearing on the radio or watching on TV or
choosing to watch on a podcast, if you don't like it, turn the dial.
I don't want people turning the dial. I actually, I want to build my audience.
Um, but I'm not going to compromise who I am,
what I want to say or the values I stand for because they're going to try to
intimidate me in silence, my voice. I'm not going to allow it. Um,
I am going to fight till my dying breath,
but I'll also fight for their right to do and say what they want to say.
They've lied. You know, the media in general,
they've 99% of them have been lying to the American people from the
day that Donald Trump and Melania Trump came down that escalator at Trump tower.
Looking for more honest and thoughtful conversations about the media instead of
nonstop yelling checkout our media playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews on a variety of topics,
check out the full episode playlist,
they're both right over here and to get notified of all future videos,
be sure to subscribe and click the notification bell.